hi my name is carly rae jepsen and today
we're going to be or i'm going to be
ranking my own music my new album
dedicated is out but we are going back
in time all the way to kiss era sounds
like so yeah first up now that I found
you or cut to the feeling I mean cut to
the feeling holds a very special place
in my heart
probably because I was in Italy when it
came out and it was such a surprise to
me that it seemed to connect I don't
know
I do love a cat video I'm gonna I'm
gonna go with catch it the feeling down
didn't just come here to dance and no
joke like me I'm gonna go with no jug
like me it's a little darker a little
bit more serious I'm picking these based
off of today by the way cuz it my
opinion changes depending on my mood I
really like you or call me maybe I mean
I know I've sung it a lot but I'm gonna
go back to like a new love affair with
call me maybe just because you know wow
I'm about to go on tour I got a relearn
those lyrics mmm that's a joke
this kiss and want you in my room I'm
gonna go with wat you in my room
it's cheeky they're both very cheeky
songs but want you in my room is a
little bit more cut and dried right to
the point
run away with me or tiny little bows
fool run away with me I'm a sucker for a
sax good time and let's get lost let's
get lost again for the saxophone reason
Julian and all that that's not fair it's
not fair
cuz Julian is the heart of this new
album dedicated and all that is the same
for emotion so you killing me with this
one I'm gonna go with with Julian
because it's it's new it's fresh blood
warm blood or give me love I think I'm
gonna go with warm blood it was my
introduction to rostam they've gone with
a little tune it was a new thing for me
to share that I've written a lot of
songs these are just the funds that have
been released I'm starting tonight I'm
getting over you or what I needed you
what I need you for sure that one's
always really find this thing live
because everyone always takes over for
me so I've got good good memories of
that one party for one or boy problems
you know similar themes there I guess
man I'm going off of today my vibe today
is gonna go for nostalgia weirdly I'm
gonna hit back to little boy problems
but that's a pretty awful
like even tie for me I'm kind of sad
undoing that maybe I changed my answer
I'm gonna like to change my answer in
the middle I'm doing a switch I'm going
for the new blood potty
full one baby your type or turn me up
your type I'm breaking up with you you
kiss me on the book I haven't sung that
song in years
I forgot it but I'm still sticking with
your type too much or store ok store is
a song that people love to hate and I
don't care i weirdly think it's the
strangest song I've ever been a part of
making and it makes me laugh but too
much is my new single coming out and at
the moment is a contender for winning
this whole damn race stuff gonna go with
too much cry or fever
I think favorite wins automatically in
love or favorite color we're gonna we're
gonna let Mariah Carey win with
automatically in love we're gonna go to
the 90s I think feels right or curiosity
Oh
curiosity is an old one that's it's from
before call me maybe even the feels
right was how in the ASA and friend I'm
gonna go with feels right here and then
last but not least real love and emotion
I'm gonna have to say emotion on that
one this is a cool game who made this
game okay cut to the feeling or no drug
like me I'm just gonna do it quick like
word-association pick fast ah don't ask
me why but no drug like me I love that
I'm playing with myself in this case all
right Carly come on baby I want you in
my room
I want you in my room yeah run away with
me or let's get lost run away with me
Julian will warm blood Julian by the way
for the collaborators involved in this I
love all of you and no song is better
than another it's just for the moment
when I needed you or party for one I
actually I'm surprised I doubted but I'm
gonna go back with a little party for
one your type or too much too much fever
or automatically in love this could be
that I'm like these on the news
because I'm excited that I'm gonna go
with automatically in love feels right
or emotion emotion still takes over that
one
no sorry kiss you've been passed on it's
a really love your little pink records
okay it looks like a no jug like me or I
want you in my room
Oh Alec it's tricky
very different songs at this point so
that's really hard I'm gonna go with
what I feel like right now I'm gonna go
with want you in my room run away with
me or Julian that is not fair either I
don't like this corner this is a mean
corner I'm gonna draw a circle and say
beware this corner um this is why no one
ever gives me clipboards
run away with me yeah too much nostalgia
party for one or too much a little too
much automatically in love or emotion
emotion want you're in my room or run
away with me run away with me yeah that
wind that was that's no it's not a fair
one there's too much memories too much
or emotion I'm gonna go too much sorry
emotion I'm so sorry I'm sorry
and then last too much but run away with
me I mean you have to understand I just
shot this video for too much yesterday
and there's nothing in the world that
I'm more excited about we're gonna go
it's too much as our winner winner
chicken dinner
yes
[Music]